sortir de l'ombre documentaire exclusif
signé par Clélia chaffeur qui a suivi
ici vous venez de le voir le travail
réalisé par l'association La Lucarne
d'Ariane qui accompagne d'anciens
détenus dans leur recherche d'emploi au
sein des métiers de la culture et du
spectacle vivant l'occasion de
s'interroger plus au-delà maintenant sur
les obstacles à franchir avant de
trouver un emploi après un passé
carcéral c'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débadoc aujourd'hui Hervé
Mony est avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
le directeur du service pénitentiaire
d'insertion et de probation de la scène
sainten qui dépend bien entendu du
ministère de la Justice vous faites
d'ailleurs partie des personnes
remerciées à la toute fin de ce film
dans le le générique le service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation le spipe on en parlera avec ce
terme dans cette émission ont été créés
en 1999 il en existe en France
aujourd'hui 103 sur l'ensemble du
territoire et puis au sein de ces SPIP
exerce des conseillers pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation ce sont
environ 4000 CPIP qui suivent
aujourd'hui et qui accompagnent plus de
74000 détenus en France dans
187 établissements pénitentièes et
approximativement 165000 personnes
suivies en milieu ouvert hein cette fois
euh remarque un c'est PIP peut avoir à
sa charge le suivi de 90 à 120 personnes
autrement dit on ne parle pas vraiment
d'un suivi personnalidé au vu de ces
chiffres le SPIP que vous représentez
sur ce plateau a pour mission principale
la prévention de la récidive on va bien
sûr revenir avec vous sur le film que
nous venons de voir et les
problématiques qu'elle soulève Elsa
fossillon est également sur ce plateau
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes député
communiste de la première
circonscription des hautes scènes vous
avez mené avec la députée Renaissance
Caroline Abad une mission d'information
sur les alternative à la détention et
l'éventuelle création d'un mécanisme de
régulation carcérale vous nous
expliquerez peut-être de quoi il s'agit
tout à l'heure c'est un travail qui a
duré 5 mois vous avez auditionné plus de
100 personnes vous avez même été au
Pays-Bas he pour voir c'est toujours
intéressant d'ouvrir les fenêtres de
voir ce qui se passe à l'extérieur c'est
ce que vous avez fait et vous avvez
rendu le rapport de cette mission au
mois de juillet dernier et puis enfin
clotile Gilbert est avec nous bienvenue
après des années passées en tempant
commonier de prison vous avez observé
vous avez observé près hein ce qui est
la réalité de ce milieu carcéral et bien
vous avez fondé voilà bientôt 10 ans
maintenant hein c'était en 2014
l'association wake-up café pour
justement guider les anciens détenus
vers la réinsertion professionnelle vous
collaborez aujourd'hui semble-t-il votre
association avec plus de 300 entreprises
et vous avez réussi à tisser un
formidable réseau vous avez dû vous
reconnaître en grande partie par le
travail que nous avons vu à travers ce
film de la lucarne d'Ariane j'imagine
complètement d'autant que la lucarne
d'Ariane est un des partenaires de wup
café on a des wakers qui ont travaillé
chez eux h alors un taux de réussite ou
ou de non récidive important pour votre
association vous avez trouvé vous euh de
bonnees voies pour remettre sur le
marché de l'emploi les anciens détenus
auxquels vous avez eu affaire oui ce qui
nous ce qui nous a paru le plus
important c'est un de redonner à ces
personnes l'envie d'avancer de devenir
citoyen à part entière dans notre
société et de le faire grâce à un
encadrement très bienveillant mais très
exigeant et de fait la direction de la
statistique du gouvernement a analysé
l'ensemble des personnes accompagnées
par makeup café depuis le début et on a
un taux de retour en prison qui est de
12,6 % voilà qui peut
très inférieur au taux de récidive
auquel on fera référence tout à l'heure
hein mais ce sont des résultats
effectivement euh euh très en dessous
hein de la moyenne nationale aujourd'hui
concernant la récidive avec votre
association wakeup café
euh l'exercice l'activité est
obligatoire hein depuis une loi
pénitentiaire de 2019 ça d'une part et
puis d'autre part le le code pénal le
code de procédure pénale prévoit que les
établissements pénitentiaires doivent
prendre toutes les dispositions pour
assurer une activité professionnelle aux
personnes incarcérées qui en font la
demande voilà ça basiquement voilà ce
qu'on qu'on propose au aux détenus
lorsqu'ils sont en prison parce que il
faut commencer par là parce que nous
voyons pas dans ce film la réinsertion
professionnelle se prépare pendant
l'incarcération ouis et c'est le rôle
notamment des conseillers pénitentiaires
d'incertion et de probation qui sont
accompagnés bien évidemment par des
assistants de services social sans doute
en nombre insuffisant dans nos services
également n'ai pas
cité pas cité OUA et qui vont assurer
donc un accompagnement je vais vous
parler de ce que je connais bien le
département de la saine saintis et plus
précisément de la maison d'arrêt de
Villepinte qui va connaître dans
quelques mois un nouvel établissement
rattaché à sa direction qui sera la le
le service la structure d'accompagnement
vers la sortie mais nous aurons
l'occasion de de l'évoquer
para parce que ça fait parti de ces
structures que tent de mettre en place
et d'accélérer d'ailleurs he la mise en
place de ces struc
et les conseillers pénitentières donc
assurent ce cet accompagnement un
accompagnement individualisé nous avons
la chance sur ce sur ce département en
tous les cas en en en milieu fermé c'est
notre jargon milieu fermé pour pour
parler de des des personnes qui sont
incarcérées euh en moyenne 60 personnes
confiées à un conseiller pénitentiaire
d'insertion et de probation et tout
l'enjeu dès le processus arrivant qui
est normé qui répond à des règles
pénitentiaires européennes va être
d'établir un diagnostic pour dégager
l'orientation et le choix des
partenaires qui sont les plus adaptés il
faut savoir que l'un des travails l'un
du des axes essentiel dans
l'accompagnement des personnes ça va
être l'orientation vers des partenaires
compétents institutionnels ou
associatifs et pour ça le ministère de
la Justice a fixé un certain nombre a
signé un certain nombre d'accords cadres
nationaux qui sont ensuite déclinés dans
un au niveau interrégional et ensuite au
niveau départemental le le choix du
document
en tous les cas l'axe qui est privilégié
est celui de l'insertion par l'activité
économique la formation professionnelle
c'est notre sujet mais je tiens je tiens
effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison je tiens à souligner que le le
service le SPIP et notamment les
conseillers pénitentiaires vont assurer
un accompagnement conséquent avec des
partenaires compétents dans les trois
autres piliers de l'insertion qui sont
évidemment l'accès aux soins le soin qui
peut être un préalable indispensable
notamment à à à un emploi et puis enfin
l'accès à l'hébergement et au logement
qui est qui est essentiel bien entendu
alors c'est vrai que sur le papier on se
dit tout est en place pour procurer une
activité au sein des des établissements
pénitentiè une formation
professionnelle de l'enseignement aussi
de l'activité sportive culturelle et
puis quand on regarde dans le détail bah
finalement la réalité des faits c'est
pas vraiment celle-là parce que à cause
de la surpopulation carcérale auquelle
nous devons faire face aujourd'hui tout
cela a bien du mal à se mettre en place
dans la réalité des faits est-ce que
c'est aussi le constat que vous avez
fait à travers votre votre travail et
votre mission d'information c'était pas
à la base le cœur de notre mission
d'information puisqu'on devait regarder
les alternatives à la au à la détention
justement et en réalité ça peut pas vous
échapper dans le tableau général et
merci d'en d'en parler 74000 détenus
actuellement pour 60000 places la France
a été condamnée à plusieurs reprises par
la Cour européenne des droits dro de
l'homme pour des traitements inhumains
indiges dégradant ouais et ça de fait
c'est un frein j'ai vu j'ai vu en dans
des visites lors de visites où il y a
des matelas au sol j'ai vu des cellules
où il y avait quatre détenus euh et où
et bien les personnes qui sont là ne
peuvent pas
accéder de la bonne manière en tout
cas à des
activités à à des formations tout
simplement parce que la surpopulation
limite considérablement et bien les
mouvements au sein au sein de de la
prison à capare évidemment de manière
importante les personnels qui ne sont
pas en nombre suffisant et puis bah pour
les conseillers de probation et
d'insertion forcément fait aussi si si
leur leur nombre à eux ne sont pas
suffisants fait exploser le nombre de
situations à suivre c'est vrai que les
règles européennes en terme de probation
c'est normalement 60 personnes à suivre
j'ai rencontré de nombreux conseillers
de probation 90 110 120 personnes à su
et donc évidemment cette surpopulation
elle limite considérablement bien le
travail d'accompagnement qui doit être
un accompagnement
individualisé très soutenu et donc pose
des freins en tout cas aux objectif moi
je dis plutôt réintégration citoyenne et
donc la réinsertion professionnelle en
peut en faire partie mais il n'y a pas
uniquement ça vous parlez du soin de
l'hébergement mais c'est aussi tout
simplement retrouver de l'autonomie par
la détention vous connaissez bien le
milieu carcéral c'est peu de le dire
vous faites le même constat avec
quelques nuances et ensuite vous
répondrez
he ben je fais le même constat en
sachant qu'effectivement de de mieux en
mieux il y a une activité proposée au
détenus de fait il y en a que un tiers
d'entre eux qui ont réellement une
activité quelle qu'elle
soit mais il y a un vrai un vrai effort
qui est fait par le gouvernement et le
ministère de la Justice avec notamment
avec la IP pour créer de l'activité
professionnel pour créer de la formation
professionnelle pour créer des parcours
de préparation à la sortie donc les
choses vont dans le bon sens de fait il
y a il y a trop de personnes incarcérées
et voilà nous AC Cup café on travaille
en partenariat très étit vous nous
précisiez quand même à qui on a affaire
cette cette cette population he qu'on a
découvert alors là ce sont des jeunes
qu'on a vu dans ce film mais on a à en
faire une population qui est très peu
formée euh niveau d'éducation très
faible ah bah les je crois que c'est 60
% d'entre eux qui n'ont pas de diplôme
et qui n'ont pas atteint le le brevet
des collèges donc effectivement on a des
personnes qui sortent de prison qui ont
été sans activité pendant un certain
temps et qui doivent retrouver l'énergie
et la capacité d'agir dehors c'est c'est
vrai que c'est très compliqué sans un
accompagnement rapproché on peut être
diplômé en prison aujourd'hui on peut
être formé obtenir des diplômes de
formation
professionnelle on peut acquérir une
expérience professionnelle en prison
tout de même oui ah oui oui oui oui il y
a beaucoup de choses qui sont mis en
place pour pour ça mais pas pour un
nombre suffisant peut-être il faut
préciser juste que en pris il y a des
personnes qui ont été donc condamnés et
qui savent combien de temps ils vont
passer en prison même s'il y a des
aménagements de peine et tout ça mais il
y a une surpopulation qui est aussi le
fait beaucoup de la détention provisoire
donc des personnes qui sont en attente
et bien de la du jugement et qui passe
un certain nombre de mois ça peut
arriver et même de longs mois et ces
personnes là qui constiue quand même une
partie importante des personnes
aujourd'hui en en maison d'arrêt elles
vont avoir quand même beaucoup moins
d'activité proposé et échappe souvent au
conseiller de de probation et
d'insertion pour commencer à entamer un
parcours puisque ils ils n'ont pas
encore la condamnation et donc ils
savent pas encore combien de temps ils
vont passer là et parfois quand la
condamnation tombe en réalité et bien
c'est les mois qu'ils ont déjà passé qui
vaut pour peine et ils sortent sans
avoir eu l'accompagnement nécessaire
pour leur sortie herbemie oui il me
semble nécessaire de de rappeler
quelques éléments de de la surpopulation
carcérale est-ce que ça vous pose un
problème vous à votre poste aujourd'hui
pour aller au bout de votre mission
évidemment et ça personne le taux de
récid personne ne peut le nier un taux
d'occupation des établissements qui est
qui est un obstacle à une prise en
charge parfois de de qualité néanmoins
ce que je tiens à dire
c'est que l'ensemble des acteurs
pénitentiaires font un travail quotidien
remarquable pour lutter justement contre
des des conditions contre une
promiscuité et les conditions
dégradantes ou humiliantes que vous
citez en tous les cas je ne les ai pas
observé dans les établissements où j'ai
travaillé et notamment au sein de la
maison d'arrêt de de Villepinte nous
avons àaire à une population toutes les
populations incarcérées ne se valent pas
bien sûr vous avez effectivement
cité une catégorie de moins de 30 ans
qui est à hauteur de 45 % Dansou c'est
45 % des détenus en FR personnes
incarcéré faut savoir que ces personnesl
ont un parcours chaotique et ce
malheureusement dès l'enfance qui s'est
prolongé durant l'adolescence et que
nous avons un cumul de facteurs de
vulnérabilité qu'il va falloir traiter
l'accès au soins l'accès au droits la
formation professionnelle et
l'administration
pénitentiaire même si elle le fait sans
doute de manière incomplète tenu d'un
d'une augmentation conséquente des
incarcérations mais encore faut-il
rappeler que c'est l'autorité judiciaire
dans le cadre de de de de procédure
d'instruction criminelle ou
correctionnelle là encore l'horizon
n'est pas le même en terme de de suivi
et d'accompagnement mais aussi de
condamnation et peut-être que nous
évoquerons les
condamnations à des à des durées courtes
qui sont pas forcément et et la
recherche les recherches dans le monde
donneent des des données enfin nous nous
communique des données données probantes
qui mettent en avant l'intérêt d'être
sur des mesures restrictives de liberté
alternativ à l'emprisonnement mais le
enfin ce que je tiens à dire c'est que
effectivement un taux d'occupation très
important de certains établissements ne
nous empêche pas de développer des des
partenariats des partenariats que je que
j'évoqué de manière très généraliste
tout à l'heure mais qui sont déclinés et
notamment dans l'accès à à l'emploi ou à
la formation professionnelle W café est
l'un des partenaires mais nous avons
d'autres partenaire SP qui s'appuie sur
un réseau d'acteurs locaux économiques
et tout l'enjeu va être de mobiliser les
les personnes détenues de définir un
projet et de s'engager dans un projet
tout à l'heure j'ai dit que l'activité
était obligatoire et elle est proposé
soit par le SPIP soit par le directeur
de l'établissement par la détention tout
à faitou on a cité les activités en
question ça ne se fait pas sur la base
du du volontariat seulement c'estàdire
que ou par rapport à ce que vous
constatez il y a-t-il beaucoup de ces
détenus de moins de 30 ans qui sont
demandeurs d'une formation
professionnelle qui sont demandeur de
travailler au sein de l'établissement
via les partenariats que vous évoquez
est-ce que c'est le cas est-ce qu'ils
sont demandeurs ou alors une fois qu'ils
sont en prison euh ils lâchent l'affaire
là là encore il y a il y a différentes
il y a différents profils effectivement
certaines personnes vont attendre que la
que la peine se passe et tout l'enjeu du
du travail et l'accompagnement des
conseillers pénitentiaires va être de
mettre de la perspective dans un cadre
de contrainte de dégager un programme
qui est clairement défin et enfin de
développer des stratégies qui favorisent
la réceptivité des personnes parce qu'il
est bien évident que si au départ nous
ne travaillons pas sur l'adhésion sur la
motivation il n'y aura personne en terme
de de projet de de réinsertion donc tout
l'enjeu va être effectivement de repérer
les besoins de la personne et de
solliciter les bons partenaires en tous
les cas les
les bien CIBL le partenaire pour
répondre au besoins de la personne on va
voir un extrait du du
documentaire autour de de la privation
d'autonomie à la sortie de prison cette
fois et évidemment ce sont des
responsables de la lucarne d'Arian qu'on
a suivi don on a suivi les membres au
plus près dans dans ce film qui
s'exprime ce temp les Barou privé de
liberté mais aussi d'autonomie a des
choses qui sont pour nous
il dou je TR pourecter les hires sur les
S culturell j'ai JIS de problème par
contre prévoir son petit en cas aucun
l'avait fait parce que ça en fait c'est
des trucs qu'ils ont complètement oublié
de faire et d'apprendre je pense P la
détention va y avoir des trucs qui leur
semblent complètement venus de l'espace
à nos salariés en insertion il va y
avoir des trucs qui leur sembl
complètement venus de l'espace à nos
salariés en insertion c'est à peu près
dans cet état là que vous récupérez
alors les jeunes puis son plutôt des
jeunes qu'on a vu dans ce film ou de
toute façon les personnes qui qui qui
sont sortis de prison et qui cherchent
justement à se réinsérer
professionnellement alors en fait on se
rend compte ce qu'il viennent chercher
en tout cas chez wakeup café c'est un
cadre ils viennent chercher des règles
ils viennent chercher des repères parce
que souvent comme vous le disiez
monsieur Mony ils viennent de parcours
très chaotiques d'environnement et de
contexte de de violence de drogue de de
d'absence de de de psychologique
addictologie énorme énorme important
quand ils sortent effectivement sans
avoir eu d'activité la sortie est très
compliquée pour continuer à avancer se
mettre
debout clairement quand ils arrivent
chez nous le le la question de l'horaire
nous est pas si évidente que ça et c'est
un des gros travails que fait wakeup
café sur critères de fiabilité les
horaires hein c'est ce qu'on a compris
par exemple AC fil puisque ce qu'on leur
dit c'est que dans le monde
professionnel si tu arrives 5 minutes en
retard en fait ben ton patron tu vas lui
avoir manqué pendant 5 5 minutes et ces
5 minutes elles sont importantes pour
l'activité anciens détenus que vous
accueillez au sein de de wakeup café
sont des détenus que vous aviez
préalablement déjà suivi lorsqu'ils
étaient emprisonnés ou alors la plupart
c'est des personnes qui nous sont
envoyées par les le SPIP des des
différents établissements pénitentiaires
qui nous les orientent parce que ils
estiment que c'est des personnes qui ont
besoin de cet accompagnement très
rapproché que wakeup Café propose très
exigeant en lien avec le monde
professionnel puisque comme vous le
disiez on a effectivement beaucoup de
d'entreprises partenaires qui sont à nos
côtés qui ont compris qu'il y avait un
enjeu de de de un enjeu de
société à embaucher et à donner une
nouvelle chance à des gens qui avaient
fait un ou plusieurs passages en prison
Elsa fussillon qu'est-ce que vous en
avez pensé de ce ce film où on voit ces
jeunes qui sont là pour le coup bel et
bien sorti de prison mais on voit qu'ils
ont tout de même les plus grandes
difficultés à se réadapter et à
retrouver une vie sociale et c'est moi
ce qui m'a évidemment ça a fait écho
aussi au au travail au travail que j'ai
mené et puis au aux nombreus aux
nombreuses visites
parlementaires j'essayie d'exercer très
régulièrement mon mon droit de visite
parlementaire puisque les les
parlementaires peuvent exercer un droit
de visite dans les lieux de privation de
liberté donc que ce soit en prison en
hôpitaux psychiatrique ou encore hier
j'étais en centre de rétention
administrative euh est-ce que vous allez
aussi dans les associations de type oui
bien sûr enfin alors jamais mais
bienvenue sera peut-être le cas après
cette émission on verra mais moi ce qui
ce qui a fait écho en tout cas à à ces
parcours c'est l'idée il y a un des un
des anciens détenus qui qui dit j'ai
plus de mémoire j'y arrive plus à penser
en gros il explique comment tout ça l'a
brisé aussi il y a le rapport au temps
que la la la salarié de de la lucarne
évoque enfin il faut que les gens
essaient peut-être de s'imaginer même
c'est très difficile hein les les 24
heures alors pas pas 24 he dans une
cellule mais pour certains ça peut peut
être 22 ça peut être 21 des fois c'est
moins mais 21 21h 22h dans une cellule
vous imaginez bien que la notion de
temps elle vous échappe totalement et
donc je dis ça parce que il faut pas
minimiser à quel point la prison ça ça
brise des choses c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
déjà des parcours chaotiques avant euh
mais mais la prison elle brise m quours
chaotiqu aès aussi mais la prison c'est
c'est ça brise même de semaines même un
mois on parle de choc carcéral euh et
donc même s'il y a un accompagnement en
prison et effectivement il y a des
associatifs il y a des partenaires
institutionnels il y a les S pipes les
psychologues qui sont qui font un
travail absolument considérable mais il
faut bien se rendre compte que à
l'intérieur de la prison euh il y a un
travail qui est aussi limité par l'effet
produit par l'incarcération et que la
prè est rendu très difficile aussi par
les effets continu de de de cette
incarcération en réalité l'insertion la
réinsertion professionnelle parfois elle
est pas possible tout de suite parce
qu'il y a plein de choses à réapprendre
avant et c'est ce que montre très bien
le le le documentaire il y a l'autonomie
l'autonomie par exemple oui et parfois
même retrouver je je vais aller jusque
là parfois même retrouver sa place dans
la société ne passe pas par l'emploi
parfois parfois ça passe par autre chose
trouver une autre place dans la
société ne passe pas forcément par
l'emploi alors ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'il y a des politiques aujourd'hui
très développées sur l'axe réinsertion
professionnelle on comprend pourquoi
mais parfois la réinsertion
professionnelle il faut le dire aussi et
c'est pas pour être pessimiste elle vous
replonge dans un cadre qui a un cadre
très contraint un cadre où les
conditions de travail peuvent être très
dures parce que on va orienter aussi ces
personnes à des parcours chaotiques pas
forcément vers les métiers où les
conditions de travail sont les plus euh
agréables confortables épanouissantes et
qui peuvent devenir aussi euh des
facteurs qui redéveloppent un stress des
traumas des mauvais comportements donc
je dis ça pas pour brosser en noir le
tableau mais pour que pour montrer à
quel point le travail d'accompagnement
et le travail qu' a à produire la
personne elle-même est compliqué à faire
l'administration pénitentiaire développe
des programmes axés sur l'autonomisation
et la responsabilisation à la maison
d'arrêt de saine- saintenis à Villepinte
nous avons deux Cartier qui favorise
cette mobilisation là un quartier jeune
majeur qui accueille une une vingtaine
de jeunes détenus et puis un module de
respect euh qui permet à des personnes
sur la base de la signature d'un d'une
charte d'engagement de bénéficier de
davantage de liberté d'aller et de venu
d'aller et venir au sein de la détention
et au fond le travail de
l'administration pénitentiire qui
continue important et de développer des
programmes qui vont favoriser le
développement des habilités sociales
mais aussi des compétences
psychosociales et nous déterminons les
cahiers des charges qui sont portés et
mis en œuvre par un certain nombre de
partenaires mais qui sont également
portés par les par les CPIP parce que
par les conseillers pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation et tout
l'enjeu va va être de de favoriser pour
ce public là l'accès à des codes le code
de l'entreprise le code de communication
de l'entreprise c'est pas celui du code
de communication dans la famille et
c'est pas celui non plus du code de
communication avec les avec les pères ou
avec dans dans un réseau amical et donc
ce ce travail là avec des de nombreuses
actions qui sont qui peuvent être avec
par des biais culturels ou
socio-éducatif vise véritablement à les
préparer à s'inscrire dans dans un
accompagnement post-ccéral avec tout
l'enjeu et vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure des aménagements de peine nous
avons aujourd'hui un un taux moyen de 25
% d'aménagement de peine mais nous avons
également d'autres mesures euh qui sont
décidées par l'autorité judiciaire nous
répondons bien évidemment à la commande
judiciaire des mesures de libération
sous contrainte de plein droit désormais
qui relèv de la régulation et qui nous
permettent un suivi assuré par des
conseillers pénitentiires en milieu
ouvert en les accompagnant là encore
dans dans dans le respect des
obligations et des interdictions mais
surtout dans une mobilisation et une
responsabilisation par rapport à un
projet qui se doit d'être personnalisé
on va passer à la récidive parce que
finalement la récidive et le taux de
récidive c'est le chiffre qui doit faire
fois à la fin de toutes les politiques
mis en place bien entendu pour les
personnes dont nous parlons aujourd'hui
avec ce chiffre par exemple hein 40 %
des personnes condamnées en 2019 sont en
état de récidive ou de réitération
source Inc et puis un autre chiffre
celui-ci 30 % des sortants récidives
dans les 12
mois voilà les chiffres dont je dispose
j'imagine j'espère qui correspondent à à
l'ordre de grandeur que vous avez les
uns et les autres en tête puisque il
peut y avoir discussion sur chez chiv
entre
réintégration récidive bon réitération
récidive bon on est sur un/ers de
récidive en moyenne comment peut-on un
temps soit peu faire baisser ce chiffre
C'est ça la vraie question ouis ce qui
est sû c'est qu'il il y a un gros sujet
de société et on voit que s'il y a de la
récidive c'est qu'il y a de nombreux
délits dans la société donc on a tous
intérêt à travailler et tous je parle
collectivement c'est-à-dire les
entreprises la société les services
pénitentiaires et et et les et les élus
à travailler à regarder ce sujet de
manière très proche parce que
aujourd'hui et c'est ceux qu'on
accompagne qui le disent il y a deux
mondes en fait il y a le monde de la
cité si je caricature un peu et le monde
de la société et donc tant qu'on
continue à avancer avec des silos où
chacun reste avec ses codes et avec la
perception qu'il a de l'autre silo les
choses ne vont pas aller en s'améliorant
en tout cas c'est ma conviction et je
pense qu'elle est qu'elle est partagée
donc tout ce qui va permettre de créer
des ponts entre ces ces deux ces deux
mondes est
indispensable du coup un des gros
travails c'est de permettre à ceux qui
sont en détention de se projeter vers un
avenir différent de comprendre quel est
leur intérêt à intégrer la société et à
y agir de manière positive et donc ça
c'est tout le travail travail qui est
fait déjà effectivement en détention et
qui est accompagné à l'extérieur vous
AZ café vous l'avez cité tout à l'heure
je crois que c'est 12,5 % malgré tout
malgré tout chez les personnes qui ont
récidivé qui sont passé par wakeup café
qu'est-ce qu' a qui a fait qu'ils ont
récidivé qu'est-ce qui a raté bah il y a
plein de choses des personnes où on
était convaincu al on a créé un lieu où
on les embuchche dès la sortie de prison
pour leur donner d'abord un salaire
parce qu'on sait qu'un certain nombre
d'entre eux si on leur donne pas tout de
suite un salaire en fait ils vont aller
continuer ce qui les a conduit en prison
en sortant ils ont tous la motivation de
faire autre chose 3 jours 3 semaines
peut-être 3 mois mais ça ça dure pas et
s'il y a pas un salaire qui leur qui va
les les garantir qu'ils ont un minimum
un minimum vital ils vont continuer à à
créer de la récidive et ils vont
continuer à retourner en prison trois
fois qu fois 5 fois Elsa fossillon vous
avez travaillé sur les alternatives à la
prison c'est presque votre choix de de
bataille hein à l'occasion de cette
mission avec votre collègue de de
renaissance c'est une des solutions
possibles les alternatives à la prison
pour résoudre ce et faire baisser ce
fameux taux de récidive il y en a
d'autres
peut-êtrejà déjà sur le taux de récidive
il faut dire combien on a un petit souci
en France avec les chiffres et les
statistiques sur les données de justice
et et sur les données liées à la prison
et et donc nous on a plaidé avec ma
collègue pour vraiment se doter euh de
de de de chiffres un peu stables
consistant s'appuyant aussi sur les
parcours les trajectoires c'est
important parce qu'on sait combien c'est
une trajectoire la sortie de de la
délinquence et donc parfois vous
récidivez mais vous
récidivez en en distanant un peu les
actes de délinquence que vous commettez
euh parfois c'est pas tout à fait les
mêmes choses et vous allez commettre des
faits moins graves et cetera donc tout
ça c'est à analyser parce que c'est pas
parce que en gros la personne recommet
un un acte un délit une infraction que
ça veut dire que elle est pas en voie
d'en sortir ça c'est la première chose
et donc on a besoin pour pouvoir voir ce
qui est efficace de pouvoir analyser ses
trajectoires ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième c'est on a besoin aussi
d'outils pour voir justement si les
alternatives à la détention sont plus
efficaces c'est pour ça qu'on a dû aller
ailleurs on a été au Pays-Bas parce
qu'ils se sont dotés d'outils
d'évaluation et de criminologie plus
consistant que les nôtres et ça a l'air
de montrer quand même que les
alternatives à la détention sont plus
efficaces je cite une étude américaine
aussi qui est un peu daté maintenant qui
dit que toute année supplémentaire
passer en prison augmente de 6 points le
risque de recommettre un infraction et
baisse de 4 la chance de retrouver un
EMP un emploi donc ce qui montre bien à
quel point la déttion elle va fragiliser
et elle peut elle peut être quelque part
contraire non pas à la mission de
punition qu'on fixe aussi à la prison
mais qu'elle oui parce qu'il faut aussi
penser aux victimes on pense beaucoup au
au détenus on va
auss donc il y a l'idée on enferme parce
que il faut punir d'abord est-ce que il
suff enfin est-ce que punir ce n'est
qu'enfermer mais ensuite il y a la
mission aussi remettre quelqu'un dans la
société qui ne va pas recommettre
d'infraction et là on se rend compte
quand même que la prison est
particulièrement inefficace pour
répondre à cette mission et par
alternative à la prison vous entende
alternative à la prison alors il y en a
il y en a un éventail qui existe év coup
connaissent les tiges les travaux
d'intérêt général il y a aussi ce qu'on
appelle les le placement extérieur donc
vous allez pas être en prison mais vous
allez être accompagné de manière très
resserrée moi je crois beaucoup en cette
formule parce qu'elle permet un
accompagnement très suivi et très
individualisé euh je je mets pas par
exemple le la détention à domicile avec
bracelet électronique qui est pour moi
une mesure de contrôle plus qu'une
véritable mesure parce que
l'accompagnement est très limité par
exemple je je je pense donc mais mais ça
ça demande presque un changement de de
culture judiciaire et et un changement
de culture dans la société dernière
question avant de poser la vous donner
la parole hervmy l'aménagement des
peines vous l'avez évoqué ça semble une
piste souvent mise en avant c'està-dire
c'est un sas en réalité entre la la
prison et et et l'accès à sore ce qui
est important c'est de pas être en
sortie sèche c'està-dire que c'est sûr
que si vous avez eu des conditions
détenenstion terribles et qu'en plus
vous sortez et qu'il y a très peu
d'accompagn
là vous faites le pire qu'on puisse
faire à la société et à la personne
détenue je vous donne la parole vous l'z
promis ça sera ça sera sans doute le mot
de la fin je ne partage pas tout à fait
votre réserve sur la surveillance
électronique c'estàdire que la
surveillance électronique va permettre à
la personne un maintien
deaccord largement supplantter les tiges
et que je préfère les tiges je préfère
un développement de tiges plutôt que
sauf que nous on accompagne beaucoup de
personnes en
amén ou dans les dans le choix des
propositions et c'est une des mission du
service pénitentiaire d'insertion que de
proposer au magistrat d'éclairer le
magistrat sur le la bonne alternative à
l'incarcération qui va correspondre au
profil aux réceptivités aux capacités
aussi de la personne d'intégrer de
respecter des obligations et des
interdictions et la sur que peut faire
le CP parce qu'il connaît très bien la
personne il doit être mieux intégré au
déc et la et la surveillance
électronique permet à la personne de
bénéficier de de for tion
professionnelle d'emploi et notre
service est particuli et notre service
est particulièrement réactif pour
favoriser pour être dans cette souplesse
là et puis avecag un accompagnement des
entretiens assurés par les conseillers
pénitentiaires à un rythme très régulier
aprèsfin je il nous reste très peu de
temps tout à l'heure vous avez parlé des
SAS qui sont ces nouvelles structures
pénitenties il en existe quatre en
France l'objectif je crois d'en avoir 14
à brève échéance pour 1800
places en quoi ces structures peuvent
faire avancer le dossier et permettre de
mieux réinsérer professionnellement les
détenus c'est un enjeu effectivement
important et le ministère de la Justice
et plus particulièrement la direction de
l'administration pénitentiaire a a
fortement investi avec le programme que
vous venez de rappeler une une structure
va s'ouvrir à à noisil Legrand elle sera
rattachée à la maison d'arrêt donc de de
sain Saint-Denis avec avec trois trois
principes 1 l'adhésion de la personne
une équipe pluridisciplinaire et des
projets dédiés uniquement vers la la la
préparation à la sortie avec un certain
nombre d'acteurs institutionnels
associatifs et puis un engagement de la
personne une adhésion respect du
règlement intérieur avec malheureusement
enfin si le si le si le règlement n'est
pas respecté l'application d'un régime
de de de sanction mais aussi une un une
mobilisation et notamment via
l'insertion par l'activité économique
qui qui va qui va permettre
véritablement de dégager et de créer des
parcours dedans dehors avec ensuite un
suivi qui sera assuré par des
conseillers pénitentiaires en milieu
ouvert bon c'était le mot de la fin je
hein malheureusement on aurait pu rester
bien plus longtemps pour évoquer ce ce
sujet après ce ce documentaire sortir de
l'ombre et documentaire exclusif pour
notre chaîne et cette émission débat
dooc un grand merci à tous les trois vos
réactions ça sera sur
hashtagdbadoc et puis je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un prochain débad dooc
bien entendu ça sera à la même place à
la même heure et toujours avec son
documentaire et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt